bonjour trina bonjour nous sommes
prêts à pousser
comment tu vas je suis robert zemeckis salut je suis
kelly riley nous sommes ici à paris euh pour
le vol de première ligue
comment tu te sens mec tu as sauvé beaucoup de
vies comme tu  atterrir cet avion n'était
rien de moins qu'un miracle du
nez c'est une histoire à propos d'un
personnage très intéressant qui euh
est euh sur un vol de certains de ses propres
démons personnels et doit
accepter ces derniers le capitaine whittaker est un vrai
héros c'est toi  mentir pourquoi avons-nous besoin d'un
avocat vous ne vous souvenez pas d'avoir
prélevé votre sang la nuit de l'accident
vous aviez de l'alcool dans votre système qui
pourrait être la prison à vie eh bien c'est un
super bon scénario je veux dire que c'était un
personnage très compliqué j'ai bu le  la nuit
avant le drapeau, Whitaker sait qu'il
va aller en prison mes clients ne vont pas en
prison
il est merveilleux c'est un grand grand acteur
peut-être le plus grand acteur vivant il est tellement
engagé et préparé euh c'était c'était
merveilleux de travailler en face de quelqu'un qui a
établi  et ce talent et juste
ça m'a fait mon jeu j'ai été très
privilégié de travailler avec lui
je ne peux pas croire qu'elle n'a pas de manteau
elle est folle
c'est une fille adorable et une très très très
bonne actrice
tu me tire dessus puis-je  viens à l'intérieur ouais viens
à l'intérieur je vais te tirer dessus à l'intérieur de la faa
placé dix pilotes et simulateurs
recréé les événements chaque pilote a tué
tout le monde à bord tu es le seul
qui pouvait le faire
je veux parler des jours qui ont
précédé l'accident  vous avez sauvé ma mère cette
chose est si lourde vous savez que les gens disent
demandez-moi bien ce que vous voulez que les gens
obtiennent de ce film
ou de n'importe quel film je et je le dis toujours
bien cela dépend de ce qu'ils y
apportent le film continue également de mettre  le
public dans une situation inconfortable
où le vôtre
vous vous remettrez en question vos propres
idées sur ce qui est bien et ce qui ne
va pas en
fonction de la façon dont les
événements du film se
déroulent euh
c'est ce qui m'a attiré vers la paix alors
beaucoup quand j'ai d'abord  je t'ai rencontré
je ne pouvais pas croire à quel point tu étais un connard arrogant ivre
oh vraiment ouais oh
merci mais j'ai fait la recherche capitaine
whitaker j'ai entendu l'analyse d'expert
et je dois te dire que je suis impressionné par ce que
tu as fait
merci vraiment
pitié
denzel washington c'est incroyable tu sais
l'homme international de l'année c'est
ce que tu fais que fais-tu comment puis-je
ma tête grossit
mademoiselle missy boku
personne n'aurait pu atterrir cet avion comme
je n'ai fait
aucun vol ou cinéma